bella tutti fa vj io sono ragazzi e
benvenuti in questo nuovo video su will
seppi è un gioco strappa storie allora
dobbiamo cascato anche la famiglia
allora non mi ricordo se la settimana
scorsa l'ho fatto meno è più vispa che
ogni settimana mi invento qualche scusa
per non farlo non è vero che sono una
persona triste cosa che cosa clicca non
ho fatto ancora niente stai calmo naked
women no vabbè allora sia roba più ha
vietato ai minori su è più visto che su
youporn
a parte sta roba che non avrete visto
nievo e non avete visto niente
andiamo su salva intense cosa caso non
ho anche visto non andrà in frega un
cazzo ormai senza il pogo in realtà sto
bene sono il mio modo di fare yoga la
mattina e scusatemi non ho capito cos'è
sta roba allo scudo chiedo scudo
affanculo rafa non ci credo devo
riuscire non aspetta
ce la posso fare me lo sento un attimo
devo sentir melo dentro per perfetto
dentro il culo modo sentire bravo trio
ero vivo al momento della fine quindi va
bene va bene ne ho vinto ho deciso io la
partenza delle migliori ragazzi non ama
me è più visto ultimamente vi ripeto sta
diventando facebook vabbè ma [ __ ] lo
faccio senza neanche leggere mamma no no
cosa cosa va dove no non è vero sta
mentendo faccia di questa si sta
ingrossando un arpione non sapevo
neanche il livello come era fatto e sono
riuscito aa vinciamo vinto fotte sega
avevo vinto anche prima
inutile che fai ma [ __ ] poco
harbour perché tutto colpo logic sociali
staranno al polo a questo c'è di strano
che mi fa incazzare è una roba
sì però vi prego prendetevi tutti i nati
sana state tranquilli per l'amor di dio
aveva iniziato stupido isterici calmi
state calma mi capire come lo uso ma
come faccio così
pensai che ninja del carina st gol
ah ecco questo bravo fatto anche andiamo
devo ciao ci arrivo ci arrivò un vero
ninja si stacca da gli arpioni 9 pausa
caffè ragazzina piano
questo il mio nuovo quadro adesso lo
attende in casa anche il rag doll prova
benefico d'arredamento the destroyer
cos'è sta destruction clickblog destra
black blocks e black box i black bloc
sono quelli che se non bruci la città
non sei nessuno
don't let the thought it ground game
over ed è grazie al cazzo il partito
prima che andate a cagare per start
level ok non devo non devo non devo a
col mouse ho capito devo togliere i
blocchi è la madonna è diventato uno di
quei giochini per iphone ma questa cosa
nera vale sensi faccio così tolgo questo
questo e questo lo faccio scivolare sul
ciao ciao zio allora no cioè ho avviato
un livello no perché deve sempre vedere
gente a 90 quando avvio i livelli di
happy viscosa c'hanno in testa ai
creatori visto gioco per shanghai white
box ei non è questo il mio nuovo rpg e
spara anche presso spenti su ha voglia
si dove comprare mediashopping 5 euro
annuncia che con rpg ragazzi nostra cosa
bellissima
si muovono anche i colpi ciao padrini
gli ufficiali o che come sai a posto è
lo so lo so è una giornata di merda che
ti devo dire la vicina regali grazie
gentilissimo ciao zio eye la nuova ford
gt ti piace alla madonna vera figata
nella forza ragazzi ford per tutti da
domani quando è suonata la campanella e
non ti fanno entrare a scuola per me i
soci poi da buongiorno prof
è una cosa oggi sono eco sa che cosa
fate lezione di come infilare le
supposte nel culo in spiace sia è un è
uscita è una è scappata l'ho vista io ah
no vabbè uno per sfondare il muro ma non
esistono né quella come cazzo entrata
non ci sono le porte ma ci sarà del
casinò ragazzine do è per carità c'è
stato casino perché non sa che con un
bazooka è letale harris mezza a un
ancora bassa che stabilità nei miei
livelli di happy meals perché è la sedia
la sedia della tabitha più è piatta
questa e quella dell'ikea cioè non ha
senso il casco neonato il casco di teco
vinto io non lo sono ne sono sicurissimo
può essere di si può essere novy cas che
qua comunque nel caso la sicurezza in
questi sport prima di tutto john cena
smackdown and his name is joe sera
[Musica]
ragazzi magari john cena oggi è un po
ingrassato e un po nero rispetto al
solito quindi andiamo con nonno cia
colpo di penne di nonno ci è andato giù
o salve salve sono mi spiace non volevo
colpirla ma me ne vado a casa rock swing
ingenuity ingenuità dal rock swing che
cazzo vuol dire cosa quella assorbente
che cosa succede perché ai ragazzi le
starting bene ci sono gli assorbenti che
vola canzano nuvole shuyukh morto a caso
per tutelarsi
no no che livello di milano a piano è di
piano devi fare più è il tuo primo
livello oggi non fare figure di merda
per l'amor di dio bravissimo dai che ti
regalo gli assorbenti alla fine che sono
ce ne sono da vendere lo zio madonna
quanto mi piace quest'uomo bravo la
spaccata che sei perfetto lisa fusco
style cosa fa balla ho capito che è la
malattia della dance mastai carmona più
a questo è il must è un tipo di
massaggio famosissimo perfetto ragazzi
ho vinto abbiamo vinto degli assorbenti
ragazzi l'importante aveva vinto gli
assorbenti horror al banjo a space è la
spiegazione era una spiegazione serie
ragazzi giurò rels mitani ndash mac
index crei un the wheels del sake of the
contenga nei board rischieresti questo
vuol dire rischieresti di una delle band
slot andare lento ciao zio sei un figo
ok bene lavati i denti zio perfetto
vabbè mica un pezzo di tronco nel
nell'esofago dalla schiena però
ciao c'è un pezzo di esofago nel tronco
vuoi favorire in troppo dentro
ciao anna anche le rocce perfetto no il
mio pezzo ridatemi subito il mio pezzo
di tronco immediatamente sono mi incazzo
a devo sono vivo per miracolo ma sono
vivo perfetto è una lavativo lev fermi
sta accadendo un altro pezzo di tronco
sul collo con la madre ramoscello ho
schivato lo stimato ha chiesto uomo nero
per terre non è razzismo sei proprio
nero di tour che cosa ti ha fatto sto
tizio vabbè lo colpisca sei un
avversario temibile nel senso che mi sta
dando del filo da torcere cazzo è stata
l'impresa più difficile del secolo con
un boss di blog forum chat food racing
gara di topi herat rod detto male che
bella la capra così non ho mai vista io
sceglierei fox ragazzi che quella mi
sembra più mi sembrava più bilanciata di
tutte nov abbiamo questo ragazzi e il
livello piu bello di è più vi scrive
abbia mai visto lavate le treno ma che
cazzo yoda è difficilissimo ragazzi enti
vabbè ragazzi
e la come entro opposto bye bye bye bye
bye bye capra lurida vai e fai vedere
chi sei ma perché addio chiusa 0 devo
battere il treno e ragazzi ce la posso
fare ce la posso fare bye bye bye bye ma
stiamo recuperando stiamo recuperando
veloce occhiata ho vinto non ho vinto ha
vinto ha vinto il treno per un tanto
così li mortacci sua ancora ragazzi
problema un paio di miei livelli come al
solito giusto fuori james name usa un
computer 1200 80 x 800 1900 20 x 1200
per giocare a questo farisei sisal e
vorrei sapere se avete un computer 1200
80 x 800 come dice quali sono i monitor
nava beh non importa un computer mi
serve perché devo giocare a è più il mio
hd
mia madre cosa amo ragazzi lo giochiamo
anche se salve fa vj benvenuti in
quest'altro livello ponte kk hirschson
difficoltà avesse passato parla in
inglese aveva passato il ponte bravo
c'era qualcosa di difficile qui come si
chiama fa vj mi chiamo lorenzo oppure
pure niente ci sia solo lorenzo
e allora che cazzo di quiz e ho vinto
chi droghe prende questo ragazzo
aiutatelo poi già in potrò facciamo
sempre a questo livello di high fango
così almeno lo rende felice ma che sia
non so livelli permesso a livelli che
hai preso agli high spacciati per miei
sono morto l'importante è non perdere la
testa ragazzi cos'è dai ragioni giorgio
nora devi e dall'altra parte se io parti
su edi so che ce la fai
mica se vinco così non ti prego tirati
su e di ma ci ho provato
e stata la cosa più tragica della vita
di una what you suck your man amico mio
dai frate forza ma vaffan cuore dai zio
dai no
dove vai dove stai andando alle dove
andare insomma la bella e ormai è chiusa
o super win alla madonna
ho vinto ho vinto superbo cos'è ok va
bene zio grazie molto gentile fantastico
è stata è stato livello della vita o
ragazzi quello via episodio cosa sento
un altra domenica un'altra happy meals
altro disagio tanto per cambiare la
tizia è sempre più bello ogni volta che
la vedo che mi sento ragazzi video
piaciuto assolutamente è un mi piace al
capo gianni facebook e cavani video
trattenersi diana 67 city sky ci vediamo
fossero video e ricordate mi piaceva
tutto per la capra con con la canna che
ha vinto tutto
cioè io voglio essere una capra anzi
sono una capra però [ __ ] come quella
poeta raccontando storie
scegliamo prossimo vitobello ragazzi